STARS, DENNIS GURIANOV IS 30 SE
BEFORE
HARMLESS LOOKING PLAY HERE IN
THE SHOOT-IN. POINT AND HE GETS
TO ZADOROV.
TO THE MIDDLE TOIT.
THEY CAN SETTLE THEM DOWN A
LITTLE BIT.
GOT PRETTY GOOD
LINE HERE AND HEISKANEN GUESS
WHO GOES RIGHT TO THE FRONT OF
THE NET AND CENTRES IT.
GETACK!
ON A BIT
GETS A PIECE OF CALGARY LOOKING
AHEAD. BERS COMING BACK AFTER
THE GIVEAWAY THERE IN THE ZONE
AND GUESS WHO.
UNABLE TO
DEEP. T AND STOPS THAT CHANCE
ZADOROV ABLE TO GET CONTROL.
ANDERSSON RACING.
HIM.
HERE GOES TKACHUK.
THAT'S THE SIXTH SHOT OF THE
GAME BUT GUDBRANSON. K.
TURNED AWAY BY MARKSTROM.
THE SHOT GOES BLOC.
MICHAEL RAFFL STILL WITH IT.  R
STONE RIDE INTO THE BOARDS.
THEY BOTH GO DOWN.  OETTINGER.
GAUDREAU.
PASS